[Music]
5 26 on your Friday morning a rare
opportunity to say something's not
driving you crazy you may have tried to
avoid I-15 north of the spaghetti Bowl
the past few weekends after hearing
about Lane restrictions big backups now
the last of those was scheduled to start
tonight and last until Monday morning
taking the SOP on side of the freeway
down to one lane from Washington to the
Spaghetti Bowl but just yesterday Nevada
Department of transportation's Justin
Hopkins let us know that work has been
canceled he says the contractor has
adjusted schedules and found what they
call alternative Solutions whatever that
means but bottom line thank you to ndot
and the contractors enjoy your lane
restriction free drive on the 15 this
weekend buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone you can join the
driving you crazy conversation we are
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com